[Music]
tonight's what happens when the man up
top goes to experience life on the
bottom it's undercover warden my name's
Oliver Dalrymple
I'm the chief warden here Mackinac
County penitentiary as a warden I'm
tough but fair
I have fun with the prisoners you know
poking him with a stick
blast number where the holes put a rat
in their soup tell them their mother's
here to see them there's just me with
the hose again my favorite but I decided
to walk a mile in their shoes you know
go down live with the scum in the
squalor find out what it's like to be a
real piece of human trash here be fun
we said about completely transforming
the wardens appearance full facial
prosthetics new skin tone hand-laid
facial hair the works he then refused to
wear any of it because he quotes didn't
want to look like a damn buffoon I want
to look like no damn befoe instead he
put on a bandana and an electrical tape
mustache hey [ __ ] no it's me trickle
why hello there
the name's Jose criminals I'm a
gangbanger from ghetto will I got the
life sentence [ __ ]
next time on undercover warded more
shame
[Applause]
that show gonna be a hit that's gonna be
an amazing show